would you rather fart popcorn or sneeze
butter fart popcorn guys again farts are
funny is it an actual popcorn I'm
farting or the smell
oh no a piece of popcorn oh
does it have butter on it because it
seems like it might be a little touchy
coming out no no butter no butter dry
popcorn bad like off brand I gotta
sneeze butter then
yeah but it's already a mess
but I I don't want to dry popcorn like
eventually
chafing and honestly say you fart and
like it's a couple of popcorns and now
you've got a little a little load and
you're I don't want and what are you
gonna say no it's just popcorn it's not
poop it's just people whatever no no
it's just is that better if you're like
yeah look look popcorn yeah no not
better sneeze butter